this is thistle gun range in
Utah this is the first time many of the
people here will have fired a gun
they're
teachers I used to be a teacher too I
was a teacher for 5 years and I remember
preparing and thinking a lot about what
I would do if an active shooter came
into my classroom I have mixed feelings
about this I don't love the idea of guns
schools but at the same point I didn't
love the idea of not having any
protection against an active shooter
either I can understand why these
teachers want to learn more so let's
find out what they're
[Music]
doing I'm on my way to the shooting
range to see the final part of the
20-hour course I had an opportunity to
catch up with one one teacher
Janette so tell me why you decided to
take this course well you hear about
school shootings all the time in the
news so I figure it's better to be
prepared I mean you hope that's never
going to happen
but you never
know before becoming a journalist I
taught in New York where carrying a gun
in the classroom would have been
illegal but here in Utah teachers can
take a weapon into school they've come
to this shooting range to learn how to
do it safely so if you ever hearing
protection your gun and your magazine in
your pocket you can step in front here
and work your way down to the targets
during the school week Russ would be
teaching ninth grade history and
geography unfortunately because of the
world we live in today I want to make
sure that my I have a way to to plan and
make sure my my students are
safe teachers can be armed in around 30
States
and this course is not just about
learning how to shoot it's teaching them
what you would do if you encountered an
active
shooter this is the hot house I'm using
a desk for instance that I've got in my
classroom and I get low behind it he's
coming in he's looking at that other
corner I'm already shooting him and he
hasn't spun around in any we will put
the teachers or the participants in the
class one in each of these
rooms we will have some opposing for
some aggressors come in and they'll have
AR-15s shooting
blanks so the hot house scenario was a
lot um it felt like you were in an
action film the teachers were going from
room to room carrying their guns with
them you could see that they were scared
their hands were shaking I could feel my
heart thumping so I could only imagine
that they were also scared too it was a
really intense
scenario I just sat there I kept
thinking if I'm this scared when I know
the situation is fake how scared would I
be if this was actually going to
happen they've been running this course
since
2019 and there's even a waiting list but
I didn't appreciate why this training is
so valuable until I spoke to the sheriff
who set up the course Sheriff told me
about a time when he responded to an
active shooter situation at a local
school it ended up being a hoax but he
was really upset by what he saw they
found weapons in curses and in death
drawers and they were in places that
students could easily have gotten to
them so Sheriff Smith realized that
teachers are going to carry weapons into
classrooms in utel that's just the
reality
and he needed to train them so they
could do it properly and
safely some people want to say hey
Sheriff's Miss arming teachers that's
not true we're not doing that and these
aren't uh gun nuts they're not anything
like that these are normal people who
who want to do what they can to keep
their kids safe and perhaps in the
absence of sensible gun control policies
this is better than
nothing thank you for watching to read
more about gun violence in schools click
the link and don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe